once de pedro sanchez lily elle a
regardé plusieurs fois avant d'y croire
il y à 100000 ukrainien qui vivent
aujourd'hui en espagne nous avons décidé
d'étendre le régime de protection
européens pour leur permettre de vivre
et de travailler légalement dans notre
pays
il y a trois ans cette ukrainienne a
rejoint l'espagne 2
en 2014 j'ai pris peur lorsque la guerre
a éclaté dans l'aude en basse j'ai senti
ensuite que ça allait empirer alors je
suis parti
j'ai une fille je voulais lui donner un
avenir
mais la jeune femme n'a pas obtenu
l'asile diplômé de médecine elle
travaille aujourd'hui à madrid comme
femme de ménage non déclarés bientôt
régulariser sa nouvelle vie va pouvoir
commencer
je suis soulagé c'est une grande
opportunité pour moi et mes amis on va
enfin pouvoir travailler légalement
comme elle seize mille ukrainien vivant
en espagne pourrait bénéficier de cette
mesure et pour traiter rapidement les
demandes l'espagne a mis en place quatre
centres dédiés une heure ils ont ce
premier réseau ado avec photo et avec
une validité et avec le show du
ministère de l'intérieur et la
notification de la décision après ils
pourront avoir accès à une carte qui
documente le fait qu'ils sont à
légalement en espagne des
régularisations massives qui tranche
avec les chiffres des dix dernières
années
le ratio de réponses favorables pour les
ukrainiens étaient 2 9% aujourd'hui il
est quasiment 200 %
une mesure que cet avocat voudraient
voir appliquée à d'autres réfugiés
ceux qui demandent la ville ne sont pas
uniquement des personnes qui cherchent
une vie meilleure ce sont surtout des
gens qui fuient pour sauver leur vie au
total depuis le début du conflit
l'espagne a régularisé plus de 10000
ukrainien